encuentre los valores de cocina de teta
y se no detecta vamos a practicar
nuestras razones trigonométricas y aquí
nos piden encontrar los valores de
coseno de teta y si no detecta bueno
vamos a comenzar con coseno de teta
coseno detecta va a ser igual que es
este triángulo de aquí y el ángulo teta
es este que estoy generando tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo para eso tenemos
que recordar la definición de esta razón
y para eso vamos a usar nuestro armónico
de sol
y todas
y la que define el coche no es que
tenemos que la ce es de coseno la s del
seno y ts tangente así que acá va a
significar coseno
del ángulo theta es igual a al cateto
adyacente adyacente
adyacente entre la hipotenusa
hipo
usa
si vemos este ejemplo el ave adyacente
del ángulo es este que tiene el número 4
vamos a etiquetarlo este es el lado
adyacente a la cnte
este de aquí
este otro lado que está opuesto al
ángulo recto es la hipotenusa la
escribimos
x
luz y el lado que está opuesto a nuestro
ángulo se va a llamar
obviamente el lado opuesto opuesto
así que podemos decir que el coche no de
teta es igual al lado adyacente que es 4
entre la hipotenusa aquí no tenemos el
valor especificado explícitamente pero
lo podemos inferir gracias al teorema de
pitágoras el teorema de pitágoras nos
dice que el la suma de los cuadrados de
los catetos va a ser igual al cuadrado
de la hipotenusa así que si tengo este
lado su cuadrado 7 cuadrado más 4 al
cuadrado
la suma de estos dos elementos el
cuadrado va a ser igual a la hipotenusa
al cuadrado sustituimos 7 por 7 49 más 4
por 4 16
va a ser igual
565 esta es la hipotenusa al cuadrado
así que nuestra hipotenusa va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 65 y esto lo
sustituimos acá entre raíz de 65 vamos a
aprovechar para anotarlo aquí también
esto es igual la raíz cuadrada de 65 y
pues parece que ésta no va a ser una
raíz cuadrada exacta así que vamos a
dejar este valor tal cual y ahora
hagamos lo mismo para esta otra parte
para el seno de theta bueno queremos que
el coste no de teta es igual a 4 entre
raíz cuadrada de 65 para el pse no vamos
a usar esta igualdad que nos dice que el
seno es igual al cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa así que tenemos que el seno
detecta es igual al cateto opuesto entre
la hipotenusa ahora tenemos todos los
valores el cateto opuesto que damos que
es éste de 7
la hipotenusa encontramos que es raíz de
65 raíz de 65 y con esto hemos
encontrado ambos valores